greetings ball sniffers welcome to the
Church of what's happened now this
episode is brought to you and I love to
welcome my book e dot AG listen ever
since I started this podcast
people always ask for weekly advice on
who to bet who's gonna cover the spread
you got the Patriots you got the
Steelers the doctor the Cowboys Chicago
Mayweather McGrath don't [ __ ] stop
well let me tell you this where you're
betting it is just as important or who
you're betting on
that's why I always tell people to go to
my bookie dot AG I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do doing now today because
football seasons here college football
seasons here and you got to be ready to
go no [ __ ] okay
the season starts sadly i'ma tell you
what I'm gonna do for you join my bookie
now and will match your deposit up to
100% bonus of your first deposit up to
$1,000 you put a GNote in they put a
GNote in alright
use promo code Church capital CH you are
CH to activate your offer visit my
bookie dot AG big letters today and use
promo code Church you play you win you
get paid you don't wait till Thursday
two days later you have an envelope
number to listen how much longer you
gonna get ripped off
do you know depending on where you get
your mortgage you could save up to
twenty thousand or more but eighty
percent of people only get one mortgage
offer and if you go to your bank come on
chances are you're gonna get ripped off
screwed period lending treat doesn't
want that to happen so i'ma tell you
what they gonna do are you sure you have
the best deal right now I mean you're
sitting there looking at your mortgage
going what do I do here we go the best
deal find out how much you could save
today at Lending Tree calm slash Church
again that's Lending Tree calm slash
Church Lending Tree LLC nml house number
one one three six terms and conditions
apply kick that [ __ ] Miele
you
while the [ __ ] I got Adam ray I got
my main mother [ __ ] [ __ ] Lisa
I yet and your uncle Joey's here on
point ready to rock with you
[ __ ] before we get the podcast
started I'd like to extend my heart to
the victims of what's going on in
Houston Harvey and we donate today in
the name of the church for the Red Cross
I know they'll get 30 cents on the
dollar and that's not really enough to
cover but I'm thinking of doing a show
getting a bunch of comics and going down
the improv and getting like a real
[ __ ] shelter that's helped people and
maybe do a benefit so before we get this
podcast started just a little [ __ ]
shout out to Houston - keep your chin up
I know it's you won't even probably be
able to listen to this [ __ ] cuz you got
no I was crispy you're stuck in a
[ __ ] Jim Malay I love you [ __ ]
what's happening gentlemen how are you
what the [ __ ] is going on here what a
great great thing to do by the way yeah
yeah not not to you know spend too much
time on on that topic but [ __ ] I read
some stories and watch some images today
that we're just like I mean unfathomable
you know you're just like [ __ ] in you
know I remember in Seattle wouldn't like
flooded once in the backyard of our
house and I went out there as a kid and
like like I was like nine years old and
I was like [ __ ] free swimming pool
you know another [ __ ] swimming in the
back with one of my Playmobil like toys
and it [ __ ] fell apart and it was
like devastating but like I was like oh
it's fine a flood like then you see some
of these people were actual like boats
and cars and you're like oh that's real
they had an image they have a dog with
his head outside the sunroof yeah and
the [ __ ] wall and the water climb and
you know it's just wolf you can't even
imagine you know
this happened in Katrina what 10 years
yeah yeah years ago 12 years ago and
some of those people people who were
displaced by Katrina yeah that's the
saddest part that's the saddest part so
and um the thing that I took away from
it obviously it's like the most terrible
thing that could happen to a family to
put to anyone but it really it really
like made me almost happy in a way just
to see the response because we've been
felt for the past few months just
everything has been negative I feel like
every news story reads everyone's upset
everyone's negative and it's just that
like even though this was terrible it
was just saying if it feels like it's
like after all it's after like anything
bad it just it feels like there's still
good people you know it's like when
you're an elementary school and your PE
teacher like he's been sick for like you
know he's like the [ __ ] at your school
and he's been sick for like eight months
and then he and then you find out that
he's like coming back but he like only
to like teach some of the games that the
new teacher is [ __ ] I look this analogy
sounded great my head but I feel like
it's it's pretty close to it you know
I'm saying where basically what you're
saying is like seeing just to piggyback
on it and I guess say it say it again in
a different voice because the same [ __ ]
that was a great sentiment I can't do it
better but it was like you know the fact
that you're seeing some positivity be a
unification of people because it hasn't
happen in [ __ ] Dean I mean nine
months and the craziest thing is it's
been even longer than that
yeah like oh my god I got a lot of grief
from family members just for not voting
the last election and but my aunt who's
a little bit older said something very
and I hadn't even thing about it since
I've been in seventh grade since 2001
there's been like constant war
she's a constant like terrorist like
that that's the way it just it hasn't
really been peace for about 16 years
yeah so it's just like it it we've
almost become used to it I think and
just believe you [ __ ] walk the
Starbucks three days a week and work two
nights a [ __ ] week what conflict do
you have in your [ __ ] life you went
to college for four years
you came out here you worked as an
editor and then I got my paws on you you
work two days a week and your fan your
balls the rest of the [ __ ] time I
gotta give you a hundred bucks to get
you out of the [ __ ] house and you're
talking about the conflict have you had
in your [ __ ] life there's no conflict
you didn't vote because you didn't
[ __ ] feel like voting you shouldn't
have said nothin to him in the first
place well they give a [ __ ] just telling
me and tell them it's none of that
business are you voted for your aunt's
gonna talk to you about 2001 and
terrorists what the [ __ ] I was raised
with Vietnam when people were coming
home and [ __ ] stabbing themselves and
getting spin on his [ __ ] and that
affected me but it did not cause me to
vote you know what caused me to vote
having felonies that's what caused me
not the vote all right so stop with the
[ __ ] analogies and just kill in this
country yeah we think about everything
we have things killing us now we got two
things over thinking over thinking and
that [ __ ] internet that internet
gives everybody a [ __ ] book you know
today you're gonna see all since all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] walking in there yeah and
milania people making fun of her because
she had heels on yeah or sneakers yeah
it never ends
yeah it never [ __ ] it yeah you know
the Floyd Mayweather thing now it never
ends it's three or four [ __ ] days
then these people realize why their
lives are [ __ ] up yeah because they
focus on everything except themselves
Wow think about your [ __ ] lives are
powerful they're not even ten minutes no
[ __ ] idea what stuff there's my
friend we don't know look at that little
kid with sand in his eyes in Aleppo
having to go to a detention center
that's [ __ ] tough you weren't I'm
Boston limited from your mom's house
getting three meals a day yeah what did
you give a [ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ]
you don't care I'm not saying I have but
you know yeah you've lived through a lot
of bad [ __ ] I'm just saying it was nice
to see nice people in Hughes no no but
then you were saying the other thing
about because I've been you've waited 16
years brother by the news I'm not saying
obviously there's what the news beret
the human being what do you mean it
don't watch the news there's this much
other evidence got to be I mean there's
no good stuff the last ten minutes they
showed you a guy in [ __ ] Oklahoma
that makes tables from [ __ ] sperm and
that's build America tough and then they
show you the swimmer with no ears that
could go to the bottom
that's taking away [ __ ] 40 minutes
newscast heading hunger [ __ ] 5:30
KTLA news yeah and listen to that [ __ ] 6
into 20 after 6:00
it will pollute you for the rest of the
day it's all the craziest of the crazy
right what happens it's not like man
discovered a new way to fry hot air
balloons what happens is to Pete your
coworkers
they watch that [ __ ] too just when you
thought you were safe they repeat all
this don't you hear that chef he is you
know they're using that as their basis
for like you know just the way they
think the [ __ ] nightmare uh-huh what
we've become you know somebody had a
great quote today that the internet was
way what you did to escape from life now
life is what you do to escape the
Internet
whoa who said that somebody if people
retweeting it today I would love to know
and I would love you to know that it's
not like T it's I love like it was like
Denzel I love I love everything about
this but it really is killing us
it really is killing us you know every
time I hear about people getting run
over by a car on those terrorists things
yeah I think about all the people that
were looking down oh yeah I was raised
to walk and pay the [ __ ] attention pay
more [ __ ] attention sit straight yes
straight ahead that guy looks a little
weird you may believe you're not
watching them but you're [ __ ]
watching you know you pay attention yeah
I don't know about nothing I don't wanna
know not about nothing you know what
when I was growing up I grew up with
guys ever you got a car they didn't
giggle with nothing they pay the tension
you know we were going to Harlem to pick
up a [ __ ] half a kilo coke do you
think the world was just as scary where
you needed to pay attention or just you
always have you had nothing you didn't
yet a minimum reason to be distracted
you've always gotta pay attention I go
to a coffee shop the last four weeks
I've been going every day yeah what are
you getting it's funny to sit in between
people yeah and listen to the new
American sentiment
how people get together for an hour and
a half to discuss oh gods oh gods oh
gods you wanna stop with your daughter
and smack them in the [ __ ] face the
six of another every morning and then
every afternoon I always got the active
chick with the active guy and I can't
book a headshot that they're playing on
producing their own film and they have
drink and you sit there you want to hit
him with the chair you know listen yeah
you're [ __ ] confused black chicken
this point [ __ ] Chinese guys couldn't
get away this job at a Chinese
restaurant and you wonder why nobody
wants to hire you in the [ __ ] movies
look at my face even I got hired because
I had charisma you two [ __ ]
don't ever change
we got charisma dude charisma is the
ultimate charisma and that's what you up
but you know people don't know about it
cuz they don't have it liyan the reason
why I said that is because I don't want
that kind of different Church no more
yeah with tough [ __ ] with
soldiers the media no effect there's
nothing affects us we got to put that
out nothing bad has happened you lived
in your mother's house you never had a
weapon in your hand
nobody's ever shot a gun in you you've
never had a bomb go off you've never had
ten Puerto Ricans with knives unless it
was the song bombs we're back what I've
heard a few times what I believe oh for
the last five years it stuffing yep you
want to go eat Korean sandwiches and
convey about not convey you work you
work away from me that's what I'm
healthy we're trying to put something
together here and get the thought
conscience out yeah because that's what
the thought is yeah that's what the
thought is when you get that out of your
mind there's an American that's where
your life starts you've grown on your
own yeah when the day that you go none
of this really matters
[ __ ] what matters is I should be in
school yeah I should be getting an
education I'm this age I should be
supporting the household this is what I
should be making these are the steps I
have to take it don't happen to me I
thought well Mick Jagger's recording in
the world how does that affect your wife
yeah you know they're in studio who
gives a [ __ ] how does that affect me
what do I give a [ __ ] about Mick Jagger
that's what you realise now when you're
young you have your mind in all these
[ __ ] places for no reason
you know on Wednesday when you're young
you start thinking about first Saturday
20 you thought about South oh yeah dude
you got arrested once I didn't think
about that is you know in Rosarito my
junior year of college
it's so weird when you listen to
people's conversations in coffee shop
and listen to the new American sorrow
yeah everybody has a sorrow about
something especially in Studio City well
with everybody people love that problems
don't end up at oak people love to say
this money and they pull up dude I'm
going through something they pull up in
a BMW yeah but you don't get it they
don't you think I want to drive this car
yeah I don't understand what a nice
tough man the dilemma is like what is
that they add this [ __ ] to their lives
that doesn't belong ah dude doesn't even
really matter to you yeah you know it
doesn't even [ __ ] matter dude you got
a shelf that wants to hold as much great
stuff as possible so it's like three
[ __ ] don't it took me five years up a
[ __ ] ray to go on I had this fantasy
for five years from 1980 to 1985 that
I'm just gonna find a million dollars
like wow like a treasure like city
slickers town no no no that that's
something was gonna okay yeah that's
something was an opportunity was gonna
be so profitable that you were just
gonna buy what happened to me what
happens only in my mind somebody's gonna
knock on the door yeah
hey McManus you clearly deserved it no
no with like a brick at kaki loko i'a
awesome 16 year old runaway waited for
me to make a half a million with but my
mind was always concerned about this
[ __ ] said I had nothing I hate [ __ ]
chitty-chat like I hate small talk
really since I was a kid how do we do
this one small talk this isn't smoke no
I wasn't raised unplanned unprepared no
I don't like that bitching about the
country talk oh yeah of any situation
for more than like [ __ ] curries like
I can't deal with it now like after a
while and now at this point like I'm
done with it like I'm done with it like
I
that's my wife listen I won't do
something that bothers you can't watch
CBS CS I'm BC no more because it's
killing me it's killing me that's what's
killing American they listen to this
[ __ ] all day and man when my wife is
around me she knows I had no interest in
that [ __ ] yeah but when she's around
other people and some [ __ ] Gentile
gets that [ __ ] started about Trump or
something my wife's face turned red and
she started going off I how I can't have
that yeah the last time she did I just
got up and went through another table I
don't [ __ ] around jack but even with my
wife I don't [ __ ] around she had like a
no-trump table you know I'm saying we're
gonna disable politics payable yeah what
happened state we're talking about you
eating some chicks acid Indiana transact
yeah and also some jerk ball sits next
to you and speaking of backs we need to
support yamp yeah not swamp boys just
any of that [ __ ] any of that rhetoric
that's going on on ABC the first 20
minutes of any news so I heard I heard I
hear we have a conversation of my
Indianapolis yeah how you think she
chisel you at the door come on with the
waitress suck the addictive one night so
balanced out you know 300 senior she let
her finger in her [ __ ] we broke even
also somebody comes along it's not
talking about just something to bring
that table down about politics or even
if it's not policy related it's
something like you just said like Milan
he's wearing heels the flood it's like
[ __ ] get you you're you're so you're
so you've given over to it so much that
you're looking at the details like when
people to me and this isn't you know
hold on one second leave why he's
talking
put on sleepers there's a scene in there
I want to add him to CS w have you ever
seen that move now the beginning of
sleepers this is how I was raised
so eliminate yeah any problems you know
there was a thing when I was raised that
especially at my mother's bar I saw it
and then when they brought it to my
attention even as a stupid [ __ ] kid I
go they got a point
you know as I told when I was growing
out there was no religion of politics a
lot right like you couldn't come into my
house even as a Catholic and start
talking about some priest [ __ ] some
getting the ask sleepers bar scene
look at that line of bacon De Niro
Hoffman patrique Patrick and and and
Pitt 96
wait your mom owned a bar by the way
yeah this is a movie about those guys
called the Westies who was a true story
but the guy who wrote it afterward
finaid on the story you could speed it
up a little bit okay right there let's
see what they're gonna do it right now
where you'll hear it that's Jason
Padgett it's like Morgan Spurlock you
know as much Jason he's possessed bacon
bacon Cybercom besides he was an
alcoholic a cocaine abuser with fast
temper and a faster trigger you once
shot a mechanic dead for moving your
head of the middle movie line the dog
cat man was equally deadly and it
committed his first murder at the age of
17
in returning his paid $50 he try and he
did drugs and he had a wife he never saw
living somewhere in Queens
[Music]
to the houses he'll take another four
years to go sacred of midterm elections
Boresha or changing compensations that's
it
that's it Wow that's it that's know
everybody should watch that before they
leave the house that's it
you know I'm sold on let's see if they
keep it going yeah crank it up to the
end to see what happens
that we always be a more okay right
listen Big Dawg he won't be don't be
gone right there no I know
enjoy West Union I read this book that
I'm right and I lived I was living in
Seattle
nice 1995 when I was living in Seattle
and in 97
like my 90 City but it was gonna cover
us a gelée this book was gonna get made
into a movie and we cast it
me and Josh wolf guessed like two out of
five what we knew the Niro was gonna be
the priest and we knew Brad Pitt was
gonna be in there somewhere
no [ __ ] Pitt was just the man at the
time it was just a man at the time and
there was a guy in the book that fit
Brad Pitt's breasts now he that's great
about him he proceeded level five that's
pretty [ __ ] good ya know I cast this
movie way before where people pumped if
I had an egg in as Jennifer Lopez see
the other one cuz I want to show them
the end of the scene it's funny because
the guy that cast this movie cast
Godfather to Donnie Brasco he casts a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] let's see the second
one no the third one the third one the
third one that looks good right there by
the way there's got to be some classic
Bar scenes huh
in movie history god damn it they're all
[ __ ] people taping them with a record
all of them can you hear the sound
[Music]
this is two kids I got a rest of his
kids and they went to a home four of
them and they got sexually abused and
beat up and they were made to blow the
[ __ ] guards and [ __ ] and one day
these guys gonna have a drink and guess
who's at the body in the [ __ ] steak
who one of the guards who molested them
and [ __ ] them in the ass and did all
this watch what happens only I thought
you were didn't like the audio speed it
up a little bit they approach them they
start breaking his balls a little bit
who's we Bacon's the one that is baked
in there
[Music]
he doesn't remember them oh no and they
do
I love revenge movies you look at John
Riley and Tommy my comic
oh yeah
dish
and Walter
Simon okay kids you have and so we want
what I've always wanted to watch you die
Oh
you ordered an you know
the brisk is really good
you [ __ ] up
I'll go was Billy Crudup Jack dude he's
killing it killing it Billy could I drop
man you got a Crudup kid joke that's
what he dumped the girlfriend took he
took he dumped the pregnant
he pulled the Tom Brady did he
really--he boy he dumped the pregnant
chick the chick from weeds Mary Louise
Parker and he went for the chick from
the terrace show on Showtime Claire
Danes yep from Park of the Danes that
should be his [ __ ] one-act play you
dumped her like there's a sorry Louise
party I wonder they should have right
the [ __ ] dick go onto the table yep
yep I'm the one right to the arm
oh that one's to the head huh oh I mean
that's the way they're doing everything
okay that's how the movie starts this is
how the [ __ ] movie stuff holy [ __ ]
dude
oops you should have had the brisket
that is a [ __ ] line that's Janice
soprano in the corner she's one of the
witnesses in this look they put their
little pieces away this used to be the
[ __ ] lower west side man you could
you could shoot him alone right there
look they even tipped a guy look at the
bartender make those sandwiches to go
that look they walked out like doctors
that's how to do those cases go unsolved
look at this [ __ ] meat who canceled
his place in some places who knows what
she's saying she's probably trying to
open some potato chips to a house dude I
just pictured chips in the back of a car
like with eyes and like a voice and the
drives like where's Bertha that's the
real deal like it was no politics and no
religion so I thought there'd be no
missin damn was that Bacon's like how
early was that in the bacon career that
was 1996 all right so he's just becoming
like no he's a
we get Kevin Kevin Bacon's Abed out of
the gate right when do people here's
where I ask when do people start
thinking it was cool to be like just six
degrees away from Kevin Bacon you know
when did that [ __ ] start cuz that to me
that's almost like getting your own
cereal your tennis shoe or your toy your
[ __ ] you know your app whatever it is
like that's a stamp of approval like
that whole thing when people are like
you're six degrees away like from a god
like when you become that guy like what
have you done you know I'm saying so
when Eddie do you know at that time he
had done a bunch of [ __ ] yeah look at
him then like a tease right yeah he
started like me I mean he's still
crushing it that did you like how much
if I was that every [ __ ] is watch
that [ __ ] movie did with Sean Penn
where you played the cop when Lawrence
Mystic River no yeah Mr Quinn was it
listen standing next to Laurence
Fishburne eighties he's the best black
in front of Sean Penn across the board
there's no better african-american actor
than that man I'll tell you that right
now you want me to prove it and I love
Denzel and man I'm fine he should not
have won the Academy Award for a bathing
day that game they gave him back because
he was Africa's hurricane he could have
one hurricane by the water for mine one
before yeah beautiful mine one so it's
always but I don't think trap
whatever was his best movie anything
Fishburne is a better actor than
Reginald veljohnson who played Carl
Winslow in family matters
listen Laurence Fishburne eat up I'm the
hole laughter question Mobile African
african-american community and he could
also heat up three-quarters of the white
actors I agree with that normally he's a
[ __ ] just get let's just get something
out of the way okay right now it just
gets out my lord I'll hold you 35 how
many little company 10 years stand
Overton Union 25 yeah what were you
doing before so I went to USC for acting
school down from Seattle and you know I
came in loving comedy at the forefront
but acting was like the main thing and
then I graduated and we'd been doing
plays since fifth grade now I'm
graduating trying to build something out
of nothing I start doing YouTube videos
I start to an open mic sister we're
gonna casting Alvis I'm playing
Wolverine Universal Studios just trying
to do as much as I can to get some sort
of sort of living a life and start just
you know doing as much as I can get
material to write for when I'm doing
these open mics and and then graduate
and
you know it's like I just need to start
keeping busy - and stand-ups when that
started and and then [ __ ] ten years
of stand-up and and all the you know
videos and stuff and always the question
you should have still hum do you still
pay Stallone did you just finish
painting marvel
yeah if you were hung out with two uncle
Joey for two years I would have given
you a better experience and all that
[ __ ] is driving we'd do triple runs I'll
drop you off for the [ __ ] bar and I
the whole world love that you know it's
so weird that you go to like USC if so
like I've worked in a lot of directors
yeah you have seen they're well prepared
but they were doing the same [ __ ]
everybody else yeah like they weren't
coming out with nothing yeah they all
had kind of similar the same style and
they all came from the same school
yep you know I once heard that if you
read The Wall Street Journal every day
for four years you got more of an
education than going to college before
years like if you read The Wall Street
Journal daily from calling a god wow
that's right this is what they said on
60 minutes yeah thirty [ __ ] years ago
yeah maybe at that time what we call was
the experience of college effect was
more for the just growing up as a person
it's like I went through two serious
girlfriends and [ __ ] the amount of
drugs busting your boner but I mean no
but guess what Noah bless you guess what
though [ __ ] that I bet the [ __ ] that
you've done I would love if there was
some sort of program the way that you
study abroad like I got to study abroad
my junior and got along and I would have
loved if it was like study abroad and go
hang uncle Joey for a year you know it's
starting implementing those programs in
the college and it sounds like I'm
joking but I'm serious what if it's like
dude you're 18 or 19 and they're like
dude you want to take a you want to go
kind of still do school but also like
instead of going to [ __ ] London
you're gonna go live with this comedian
and [ __ ] hang out and see what life's
like there's not it's not a crazy idea
there's not a great comedian working
today
didn't apprentice kind of sort of like
yeah you know somebody took you under
their wing yeah somewhere along the line
who is that for you for me the first guy
was Gavin name it's HOD Jordan not a
devil who was a deadly [ __ ] comic
queen and deadly when you're clean and
deadly I really respect those until at
first I tried to impersonate him but it
was not gonna work
how'd he take you under his wing he was
very good-looking he was very
charismatic he gave me work he took me
to dungeons
he took me in a fraternity run which Oh
at the three-year mark as a comic you
fought I can't imitating yeah a very
intimidating then I got scoured by a gun
then while he was taking me under his
wing he has a gentleman we meet early
weed smoke pot we'd have dinner and we
drive together and then we went to
concerts we were also friends or with
the seal example that red rocks with
them when they regrouped and came by in
94 95 Wow him and I were friends then I
had another guy recurrent that was
completely just busted your balls was
not encouraging no no no no you know
Todd was very encouraging and he was a
sort of an education to see a
professional work yeah he had been in
the HBO comic of the year in 1985 he did
a the Comedy Festival he was named the
top 10 comedian he was a real pro and
then I got involved but I wouldn't go
ever the neighbors recurrence that your
face when you say his name was bugging
us
I don't know were clearly going for
education right yeah he would call you
want a Friday night nobody is what are
you doing about it
nothing all right you got a game
Riverton Wyoming let me give you my
address you gotta come over here cuz I
can't drive so I pick him up over his
truck hey Susie I beep he come out of
his house he'd get in the truck we
weren't in the truck three minutes I was
driving his truck he would pay for gas
meals the whole thing
oh man the first stop was the liquor
store then we get like the gallon of
mixer or whatever yeah and the ball of
vodka Negro half the mixer rat right in
the side of the road boom and we start
in the car and I had a drink that was
part of the thing but I you know yeah
that was he was my Goomba I had a
drink'll yeah with him and I would ask
him every question in the world about
comedy that I wanted to on the whole
Drive I liked his style yeah he didn't
want to do with their traditional Denver
comedians did he went to the San
Francisco Comedy Competition and came in
third he used to play like clubs in New
York he was active if he was at the
store and called mitzi a [ __ ] and was
banned from the Comedy Store for life
yeah Rickards is a real comedy outlaw
because people [ __ ] you know fake the
funk [ __ ] no Rick Kern's then when they
gonna call he's in Tennessee he was
looking for crack at night he gets
arrested and he gets into a fight with a
cop they [ __ ] tase him and spray him
with pepper spray and they put him in a
hole and every time he got hot in there
the pepper spray would come back to life
they put him in jail for 60 days Rick
Grimes was no [ __ ] joke this guy's
something whatever gather oh my god [ __ ]
your mom just so that when he said a yo
mama like fat joke he could be like I
can show your pictures on stage he was
lethal because he was dangerous in real
life so the whole time I'm watching Todd
Jordan was a professional Kanter he
would talk to what's the guy that was
bigger than 95 that took over one that I
football he killed it Dennis Miller
Dennis but no he would talk yeah yeah in
the community yeah
Dennis Miller would call him to write
for him he was the professional comic
that was very funny
Rick turns on the other hand was the guy
that when he went on stage he had six
drinks of him he'd go on stage with a
cigarette you know he heard an
impression oh no not the best body in
the world you know he had been up for
three days in the raw but he was a
brilliant comic because the danger
aspect of his app it's what made him
funny and I got to recognize that early
in it so I had to figure out how to beat
a both of those guys
Wow you follow me as because that was
the only way it was gonna work
yeah but then some change take a little
from one take a little from the other
but then something changed along the
road I went to Seattle and Seattle see
how it was a great comedy scene I used
to go downtown Mondays and got a start
number one I wish I started that are
funny you got you moved up on the list
and finally I was involved in Seattle
for about 11 months yeah I'd done well
in the festival I was getting work and
one Friday night I had a little [ __ ]
lad by the name of Doug Stanhope comes
in there who dug Stan yeah of course
when this [ __ ] savage did it be on
the ground blew your mind while people
were walking out other people were
Howard like half the room was like [ __ ]
you and they get up with their wives and
walk out and he'd go to him don't leave
I haven't done my tit [ __ ] joke yet but
the people who were laughing was
spitting [ __ ] I mean I've never seen
them like to Adam right I can't put my
Saturday gang in my Monday gig because I
didn't even know if I wanted to do
comedy anymore after you saw that
performance about how dice is performed
I think everybody's got one of those are
a few of those worried you get you ones
all season so impressive that it
overwhelms you and you go what and you
go I'm never gonna do that you just
because it looks so you feel like you're
so far away from it right brother I was
doing this now economy where I was angry
and Napa would never politically correct
but you know very tried to be
politically correct I couldn't get my
fingers around yeah
when I saw Doug's performance why didn't
I think of that right you just like
seeing him he is like a song through two
shows in a row no no there was nothing
to think about
he didn't even think about it he was
just who he was I met you were talking
about hands before yeah and you were
saying when you were saying how great it
was when i refresh me one hurts am i
doing him where I was like oh you
definitely took every part of who you
are you took the reason that they're
asking you to do the ad and you did it
because you weren't thinking with any
sort of like extra filter of like what
would somebody want who wouldn't just go
like what do I want to do I'm gonna do
that that's easier said than done in so
many things creatively because you just
you at least when there's you know the
business side involved it's
and that I think sometimes even with
like exec someone else was way before
the business side with Doug Stanhope but
he had just won San Francisco he had
moved to LA he got that shitty deal from
HBO he was just so locked into who he
was ahead
it was amazing to watch because that's
when you realize stand up for you to
pass that level you have to really be
who you are
you know like you know what I really
don't like lesbians you walk on stage
just say I love gays you're not gonna be
funny even the same because you really
don't like [ __ ] a lesbian so deep
they decide you let someone that [ __ ]
joke and there's a thousands of people
who do that type of [ __ ] to get laughs
until you really realize going up there
and talking about but whatever you say
you just gotta justify it yep and that's
what Doug Stanhope boys doing I went to
a body a day you should have seen this
strip club to check weighed about 300
[ __ ] pounds I didn't even see a bikini
but I know we're somewhere in there you
know like oh my god he was I'm just a
[ __ ] that we're coming out of him then
that he was buying flowers of the
seminal he was at a bar and a girl came
up to what a bucket of flowers with a
bucket of Rose is an estimate if you
wanted to buy her a rose for lady and he
said Liz lunch come with me with a
bucket of vaginas you know the saying
don't come over I mean just he used to
say see you imagine getting a bucket of
vaginas oh my god for my twenty two
bucks and taking the bowl mister the
[ __ ] the roses I'm going that's what
the joke was I'm gonna buy a hundred
miles and roses nobody's like my dick
but if you give me a bucket of vaginas
at least I get some I mean he would just
go off for half and then I worked with
him boy like I knew him I moved to LA
you know I would see him at the store oh
my god mitzi never really saw him for
who she who he was now so she would put
him on at 8:30 like and two women would
have to follow him and he would destroy
so hard Adam right
that he would disrupt the shows they ban
them from the improv because all their
little stars would go down there trying
to be cute and they would put Doug
Stanhope on because his manager was a
partner at the time and thank God Hope
which is all that rule
I mean comics were in the back shaking
their heads have you seen anything I
always love hearing stories of people
that can recount something that was like
the old well you just saw like such a
crushing performance do you feel like
you've seen anything
it sounds like Doug to you as some of
you've just seen crushed so hard I have
you all like is there one one we saw and
you go I'll never see something like
that again Joe Rogan at the Union
Tuesday night comedy Union no no the
Union Tuesday night July of 98 was one
of the greatest and the performances I
ever saw Joe Robert I love that it's not
great nobody won't forget 300 people at
the bar next to would jet with Jay
Davies and Dane Cook became stars Dublin
Dublin's right okay so have you went
instead of going towards the county
store you walk up that hill there's an
underground bar before you hit that
Mexican joint on the Cabo Cantina before
you hit that Mexican they used to be a
bar down there that some coke dealer had
and on the weekends he was busy but on
Tuesday nothing happened he had [ __ ]
he was first with the drapes and the
[ __ ] beds and the [ __ ] stay away
and Tuesday night was basically gonna do
a manaman hand oh no the guy that's in
every [ __ ] dodge ball dodge ball
Stiller Vince Vaughn Vince Vaughn yeah
were roommates so I met I met and Vince
Vaughn's girlfriend that he dumped the
booking the room on who's the night shed
it became this hip that was the first
room were like models and girls are
showing up
and all of a sudden it went from a bunch
of guys like us to [ __ ] stars calling
I met I met wanting to go up because the
room became so strong on Tuesday nights
so on Tuesday nights it was black night
at the Comedy Store so nobody wanted to
be there so the original room would only
have eight people the main room would
have 500 black people and white people
in that way I scared of black people so
eight only eight tourists would show up
until the original room in those days so
you had a call up every 10 minutes how
many people because you didn't want to
go down there there was no I'm gonna
cancel the show how many times you'd be
at the Union getting ready to get your
dick sucked you got a grandma blowing
your pocket [ __ ] you call this door like
that four people cancel then you're up
to ten minutes you'd have to run over
for the snow cancelled yeah because
everybody knew Tuesday nights was black
night but they get spots from it see you
had a call coast to coast if you called
mitzi in those days and said hi I went
Monday Thursday and Saturday late Mitsy
wouldn't even give you a spot she wanted
you to call in Monday through Sunday
that's something I learned early college
so even if you had a show you better
figure it out you better figure it out
because she would give me spots back
then I hosted and she gave me four out
of five spots and a main room she
[ __ ] loved you didn't she she loved
me she used to call me fat baby the
whole thing so did you love it yes I did
yes I did it was uh no when nobody else
wants you Montreal didn't warn me I
didn't have an agent you got out of a
man who got us a comedy going I had her
going you're here with us I had her
develop me make me follow Dom I went up
thought one day and I just made a
mistake like the [ __ ] that I am I
went up to him I go yeah [ __ ] the
other I had a file because everybody
said she had cameras in there at the
time yeah and then even if she wasn't
there she
is there that she was not obsessed with
the club so when I would bomb I would
just walk up to that when I'd see her
until I'd bomb and she giggled yeah and
when I told her don't put me behind on
Moreira one time that was a big mistake
cuz now every time down wherever came to
the store she made sure I [ __ ] follow
do you think that was the one thing she
didn't respond to was being told you
know don't know did she
if was she open to evening like
criticism or was it just like one of
things like look I've developed this
cachet everything I say is I calculate
yeah I trusted her with everything I had
yes okay Adam Ray starts dating Savin
Tiana
Darrel of a year goes by they're in love
and when they Adam goes on the Rose that
sticks up points this is [ __ ] it
salty calm with you and Sarah break up
and look and they got me back to MIT see
it was a great day nice if it got back
to me yeah she would make you follow
Sarah every life from now on
you would get spots every night and
you'd follow Sarah
even if Sarah went up in the mainland
yes would follow Adam right Oh does she
teach you how the could she was dog when
it came yeah dog oh she got wind that
Adam rail evil and Joe Diaz got into an
argument yeah she wouldn't give her
spots for a week and then after that for
three months I followed you or you
followed me as Bobby Lee Inari is that
that's where I wore and she would make
him what she got a wind of it that is a
bonkers but brilliant way to I mean it
look I felt the best comedy is
emotionally charged right did you agree
[ __ ] right if you don't have an
emotional attachment to what you're
talking about is that saying so to put
you in a position to where you're
following or or or proceeding
somebody that you've had a lot of a beef
with and enough beef to again like
channel this emotional charge like
timeline on your life she's only she's
piggybacking on that she's being she's
taking advantage of it and being like
but in a brilliant way where it's like
oh cool you're [ __ ] fired up right now
I'm gonna put you in a position where
you're fired up on stage right and then
you're talking about your material
through this extra level of some lights
you know like you have to [ __ ] really
up yourself to be like all right man let
me like and that I care about my [ __ ] is
as I want to care about but like if
she's putting in that position and your
and your dad were emotionally in charge
oh you're getting on set now this chick
that you dated for six years in love
with yeah she's [ __ ] the hottest
thing in comedy who's 21 he's just got
three deals and now she would make you
[ __ ] pin to finger paint with that
yeah yeah
Mitsy did that to you how to throw your
money but no let me explain something
I'm ready doing comedy ten years yeah
you've experienced a lot of different
situations when you can experience now
yeah for experience at the six year mark
it's two different situations if she
does that to you at the section mark for
the first two weeks you're gonna be
emotionally [ __ ] destroyed
oh yeah because you gotta follow a check
that you want to love it was the other
direction or the other direction she's
in love with you and you're banging the
hottest chick in comedy right now you do
you're bangin Amy Schumer in the ass and
come on the back and stealing her jokes
yeah I'm saying you having a good time
and now she's gotta follow you every
night oh my [ __ ] hating you
you know like hating you like you dumped
up and I'll say these Schumer yeah your
your man your think it's and then
thinking about it you think you really
like that I'm right if Adam ray survives
all that God like if you Adam rate went
up to me and submit to the mainland kill
me the other oh boy you would have 1245
on Saturday every Saturday for the rest
of your life yeah because she was
training you listen let me tell you
something when I was a kid I went to
karate in New York I was a black karate
school and they wore black keys with a
fist on it that said kojou oh [ __ ] you
had a [ __ ] have an identification and
yogi had to be folded a certain where
there was no worrying you you know you
see kids going to McDonald's and you
know you didn't go to McDonald's no no
you had to come to that class we closed
on like a human being
yeah take your G had to be rolled like a
[ __ ] marine blanket when your belt
loop through it you're a kid having a no
belt loops five years old you had to go
in there strap your belt on
first half I was push-ups push-ups
push-ups then it was techniques and form
and if he got a wild bug up his ass if
this guy got one by one up his ass and
there was snow outside he'd go let's go
for a run and he would take us for a run
with our gears on in the [ __ ] snow
you think any mother complained the one
on Yelp and said my kid got a pneumonia
all those kids were tougher than that
dog and yes would have said guess what
happened by him taking any neighborhood
the bullies would see you with your
karate suit on and the next day when you
came to school they would say the a
karate man show us what you know it was
a living hell it was a living hell but
my point is he walked around with a
wooden sword this guy in those days and
there was no giggling there was no lay
he said twenty push-ups you had another
twenty push-ups I'll [ __ ] stab you
didn't he say me splinter said you know
like if he went to leave like something
like me he was out of shape the first
ten classes bro you didn't do the class
two you did those calisthenics so if he
said 50 sit-ups and it took you ten
minutes and the other class was jumping
around
yes know how to do all that [ __ ] you got
some jumping jacks even while he was
teaching you still had to do with the
rest of them it was crazy but then I
went to a school in Jersey and he was a
little bit more lenient and I saw kids
when a teacher looks a you and he's in
the front of you bro and he says put
your arms up the throw punches for
example and you throw straight punches
in the a Nakia here there was always
that one jerk all that would do blocks
cuz he thought he was cute I controlled
class like a gym class and everybody
sheriff wretches yeah there's that one
[ __ ] that's doing what he's doing you
know what I just this is my purpose yes
yes yeah yeah yeah and what I'm doing
right now is what I've discovered for
myself
don't why'd you come here for well I
learned some new technique no we're
disrespecting what I'm from doing what
I'm doing no no then get the [ __ ] out
see see that right people gays you know
with the website see ya know people get
yelled on and [ __ ] you can't do that to
people getting yelped on is a new can
you imagine like back in the day
thinking that you would get public
review like that like if you have a
battle education with somebody your
business you go [ __ ] you know we both
we both chalk that up to being what it
was we got we got our [ __ ] out and you
leave as a consumer being like [ __ ]
now I gotta decide if I want to do that
again and the person of business goes I
got to decide if I want to [ __ ] get
as fired up as I just got and now with
Yelp it's like you can't even [ __ ]
get to having the the discussion or the
altercation because you're like [ __ ] I
got it just like I got a puss out on one
end or the other because I know that
likes they're gonna blog about this or
Yelp about it or something you know I'm
saying and it's gonna get tossed around
and someone's gonna read one thing about
like the guy that came to end said the
cheeseburgers were only on Sundays and
like and then they told me to [ __ ] off
and made fun of my shoes and you're like
[ __ ] I guess I'm not saying LaQuinta you
know I know it's a weird thing and I
just I don't know I don't have the time
to read a bunch of [ __ ] reviews no I
look at your wife YouTube comments or
iTunes comments or any that stuff
nothing I don't even I like I love
people leave comments it would help us
out
but I don't ask people for them I don't
know
it is weird as for the comments hey like
my stuff I mean listen I guess there
were there's a certain level that to all
this but like when you have more school
you put them yeah you put your TV yeah
but you're a beautiful combination of
olds your old school living in a new era
and you're crushing it okay so you put
your [ __ ] TV on at 9 o'clock at night
right Miami by loan or the SUV is on it
and you don't want to hear about [ __ ]
rape your sister got raped in the sixth
grade
you don't like [ __ ] ranges to now
what do you do do you stop that [ __ ]
channel and go on your [ __ ] computer
now or write a letter to ABC and say I
don't like this show SVU because my
sister got raped in the sixth grade
listen I sympathize with your sister I
hope it never happens but you know what
there's a thing called up and down on
your remote and mute and um you and me
and how our on and off you know to watch
this show that I like tackling an issue
I'm not comfortable to go to some
[ __ ] thing I got 10 minutes when I
want to date with my wife when I get
home to go on the computer and basically
rat on a place because let me explain
something to you because maybe they were
having a bad night listen guys a couple
weeks ago I got delayed
was by Southwest he says yes you know
many peeps I made not one because I'm
gonna tell you something Wow people have
bad days I lived in but I live right
here and the plane and everything thank
God it was in LAX that's completely
different that's when you abandon ship
after five hours that's what you call
the club to say that ain't happening
because they keep they keep delaying it
every hour on the hour so you know
deemed RA called me at 10:00 had already
told me your flights delayed till 3:45
it was originally 1:45 I started getting
emails anyway you put the flag didn't
leave till 9:00 do you think I went back
to the hotel they gave me on all voucher
yeah and they volunteered it to me
they gave us free drinks on the plane
they apologized a thousand [ __ ] time
hey you know many times I've taken
Southwest on a Sunday morning they've
got me back to Burbank on time like a
[ __ ] 622 thousand times yep so
one day they have a bad day you chose to
fly that bad day you chose to go a
restaurant that bad day you chose to go
into somebody's boutique on that bad day
you don't [ __ ] know if we recognize
[ __ ] though so I'm gonna go home and
make I'm gonna go home I got time off
from my busy life yeah from my so-called
I'm so creative them I'm so busy
you're gonna take time from your [ __ ]
[ __ ] life to go home click on a page
and write and something might you
justify my bad day you didn't know you
were there three times in a row listen
I'm old school first time shame on you
yeah second time what is it first time
shame on you second time shame on me
that's it
yeah it's over after that third time
show Monday twice the [ __ ] for cat
[ __ ] gorilla [ __ ] on it the glass had
[ __ ] in listen I used to go to this
Cuban place by my jujitsu school we do
we not go a few times over there we went
after your daughter's my daughter's
baptism you know what bro I went there
another time and the glass on the front
was filthy
that's a restaurant right guess the
first thing I see is a thousand
fingerprints on Sunday yeah
turned around and got Minecon and guess
what then I go home when y'all better go
home on [ __ ] hello mundo calm and I
ran out those [ __ ] have holes that need
snow yeah you don't know what people
going through you have no idea but that
[ __ ] down I don't forgive how much do
you think the world could benefit from
just the simple recognition of like
giving benefit of the doubt of like
people that are a little when you when
you sin stood as a human being right
when you sense unwarranted from your
eyes attitude how much you think the
world could benefit from you stepping
back and being like maybe that's because
they're going through some [ __ ] so I'm
gonna meet them halfway and be like I
get it but don't [ __ ] overpowered me
your [ __ ] but by me meeting you
halfway you also recognize that and then
you step back a minute and go alright
cool
I'm gonna be a little bit more 2d on
this exchange and sorry if your
Frappuccino doesn't come out as fast as
you want it or whatever or whatever is
happening right like bad days yeah
listen it took me 30 35 years to realize
when we send someone seven about there
we go [ __ ] you man immediately right
yeah I didn't think about us well if you
delay me what I was first doing comedy
okay
nine hours what would you have done I
jump off the terminal but Southwest one
time delayed me from Wade Dallas well
they also reroute you from Burbank to
Shanghai I was I had to stop that's a
real rest
that was so what one of those airports
do not let Southwest fly engine so you
have to fly into another one we got at
airport I was going to Lubbock Texas
Jesus me and Mike Feynman I was
headlining his club called froggy
bottoms I had just gone under and I've
been taken over by a Mexican family over
the taco stand next to it this is a
business and the daughter had the
biggest tits you ever seen your wife
what was her name
I'm Julia so everybody that like that
was 900 who Leah I still remember her
dog that's how she was beautiful of
course she had natural naturally she was
a little chubby so I had a natural
natural the biggest head she ever saw
and you know we were there for tonight
and they're in the Camry Club and then
they decide they want
the months later anyway yeah I went to I
got delayed at Dallas but it was one of
those delays or they go excuse me may I
have your attention our book has been
over our flight has been delayed and
overbooked if you come up right now we
will give you a free voucher for 250 and
then I'd hold out ten minutes and they
go the voucher just went up to 350 miles
I'm the first one there listen [ __ ] it's
a silent auction I got two hours listen
when you're a feature act on the road oh
you're making 550 a week yeah yeah I'm
saying
$350 voucher for sitting at the airport
and in those days I was so broke I would
shoplift at the airport yeah I would
take a newspaper can't walk you can't
get away who happened to be a card I
don't know no there's no big I see
there's a full black play that barely
speaks the language he's gonna $10 out
and they'll hold the immigration
overhead you think she's gonna jump I'll
and chase you for $50 50 cent [ __ ]
hey I would steal waters if I got
delayed Caffrey I remember one time at
Denver Airport I was going back to I was
going back I was coming back and
shooting to analyze that and I had taken
I was sober I gotta say real quick one
of my favorite movies and the fact that
you're in that and you were great and it
was just like listen that's a [ __ ] you
know front that's a top ten comedy man
had another that underage is the first
one the second one was the one I was in
which is dog [ __ ] trust me and was that
the second one yeah first one
oh the second one was brutal god bless
Harold Ramis I got to work with a legend
they're both your creditors no really
the second one is I disagree I just
lucked out but anyway I agree I was
broke before I left New York yeah and I
had a bar oh my [ __ ] my buddy at the
time was a baggage handler for frontier
highways one of those things and he had
a buddy pass they get you a free flight
on the way there they lost my luggage
when I went to read analyze that the
first time so embarrassed this is like
MoMA and hand because I was on a buddy
pass I had to go pick up the luggage
they didn't deliver it to ya that's how
they treat you like [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] Mook I'm like a buddy
digs anybody and then on the way back um
this is this is how crazy I was between
the coke this is 2003 2002 I just going
off yes yeah thing like you know it's
known wherever he could snort I got to
that Denver Airport I swear to god I got
no reason why nobody the lady there's
almost circular counters that you know
can yeah and the store surrounds it yeah
and for some reason as I was walking and
the lady was walking in the back room
and I looked and I put my hand over the
[ __ ] counter took a pack of Camel
Lights
I [ __ ] when she came back out I paid
for a [ __ ] newspaper
I put the camel whites in a newspaper
and I walked out of there
I'll never forget this I made a [ __ ]
left I walked into the men's room I need
a cigarette though I don't give a [ __ ]
about what it says I sparked up that
cigarette the bathroom I let that whole
[ __ ] thing I put a piece of dentine
in my mouth when I came out of there
whistling [ __ ] dick since Tammy I was
ready for my fight for a light oh oh
please
one time I was a little I was delay that
a bag of weed on me this ain't no big
deal dog
this is 2002 and Colorado's was huge
I mean ewr no shilling and I'm sitting
there my flights been delayed by four
never fear uncle Joey's here myself
you know I said [ __ ] it let me go to the
men's bathroom the wall the [ __ ]
number and I just go out to the Father
yeah by the way nobody in the men's
bathroom wants anything to do with
anybody so it seems like the best place
to do this is you go in the handicapped
bathroom you sit down you pull off your
pants you blow a couple farts and while
you're doing all that you roll with
joint like a doctor yes pray to God
there's no cameras in the bathroom there
is already yes you always have to assume
there is it's a natural yeah and isis's
could be jerking off in there before
they pull the switch I know if I was
gonna tell myself I go jerk off the
stick a finger by has never
if I'm gonna blow myself up are you
kidding me I'm going out deep gee I'm
going out with a ton of [ __ ] in my
stomach
milkshakes Subway sandwiches I'm splat
no tomato people gonna get with tomatoes
and mother's gonna get a 6 inch 6 inch
chicken teriyaki a vanilla shake [ __ ]
kidding me
you pass out and take a nap I smell
gunpowder if you could smell gunpowder
over that [ __ ] tornado of [ __ ] odor
and piss and men saying yes a terrorist
in the [ __ ] neighborhood getting the
bomb ready say your tea that's
unbelievable yeah they're about to think
that way no so yes I think any giant
with a malls like as much as you want to
assume dude there's probably just hours
and hours of footage of people changing
and changing rooms and people [ __ ]
and pissing in toilets and changing room
footage like you'll assume you know they
say so parable when you're in Las Vegas
a spiritual and I'll assume your life's
documented Truman Show start rumors
throw shot and when you get to your
hotel room in your room there's
something some behind the mirror there's
a [ __ ] picture of Kennedy in his eyes
move is every time you walk by them this
[ __ ] system there's a Tropicana
[ __ ] a video you know photograph of
you on the TV shame like a upcoming
attractions but it's a your eyes looking
at you like everything you're being
documented you have to always assume
Vegas we're being watch we have this on
us yeah and when you face time there's
somebody in the government just watching
you face time yeah there's people I know
hello face time with no you don't face
down no [ __ ] that's the one thing you're
like [ __ ] I don't face time I don't want
to text someone just call me I'll call
you back there's a lot more to send me a
hotmail I got hotmail on my phone I
don't have Facebook
I never bother take Twitter off the
phone let me tell you something my wife
got me she my computer's always should
have had a surface yeah there was [ __ ]
and we went she told me that I'll get
your computer that wherever your phone
could ring his computer worse so he went
we got an app
well iPad pro one of those things it's
fun right you put a writing app on there
for me and my life has changed I'm
trying to write a book oh my god I gotta
think a thousand [ __ ] words a day I've
been doing it straight since August 1st
at this kid he outlines I write oh and
I'm not gonna stop I don't have facebook
on there I don't have Twitter on I got
one thing on there Netflix so when I go
on a plane I can watch Netflix in
between [ __ ] right but I don't have
no computer [ __ ] you figured it out and
I don't want nothing but that iPad pro
with that writing thing on there
thousand I can write a thousand things
in there Lee I've learned how to write
he explored it them today
he's got the keyboard now yeah we have
the Kai got the keyboard it's a computer
and you know what when I'm on the road
on the weekends 9 out of 10 that surface
is dick and it's all the [ __ ] people
who face you Facebook you that are your
friends and you feel bad because they
wish you like a happy weekend and they
don't understand that you're going
through hell trying to answer them back
with that stupid [ __ ] surface
computer and like I said I'm the Rogan
podcast we got pissed a couple of weeks
ago and now they held it to me when I'm
on the weekends there's no reason to
tweet in my business on the weekend no
reason what do you want to tweet about
you gotta give it a breather you gotta
let that be your life break in your
Twitter break yeah yeah it's a little
weekend is just like I know why was the
weekend designed you know I got off four
messages maybe Adam ray can't get hold
of me I'll check it out four messages
sure but there's no reason the Sun if
for three [ __ ] hours just art tweeted
that that's break how many jokes you can
write in three hours hopefully a ton so
you know my world think about how many
[ __ ] John I love Twitter at 6:00 in
the morning when I'm fresh I just got
high as a [ __ ] I just did
[ __ ] three pipe fools a weed in my
yard well getting highest exam is the
best it's like I haven't done a fee I
haven't done a long time but getting
high in hot coffee
I'm like a patio when the sun's like
getting ready to come up guess what
again Isis if you're listening
there's jerk off in the bathroom please
but also so that maybe you can [ __ ]
second-guess yourself but also get high
at 6:00 a.m. with
warm mug a coffee on a patio with a nice
view and the Sun in a position to where
you're gonna view it and watch it come
up from the [ __ ] get-go and guess
we're doing so you might not want to
[ __ ] come at us you think about this
let's say you get home three nights a
week at 10:30 for some reason those
three nights am sponsored you can home
at pm and you go to bed early
and you wake up like at 7:00 you have a
cup of coffee yeah you do a half a bong
hit and you open up your notebook and
you get it and you first right now like
your plan for the day get that [ __ ] out
of your brain whatever you woke up angry
about whatever you want pissed off about
he just started writing jokes listen if
the week you're smoking is good by 8:30
you gonna be a little but you got about
an hour ago time so you're already good
an hour and a half of right and you did
your Twitter work you did your social
media work you can take a nap till 10:30
you got nowhere to go
yeah but time you're gonna be 10:30
you're tip-top Magoo you wash your [ __ ]
but you got the lunch with the
confidence of [ __ ] three guys in this
trailer so I can get avocado it's extra
but you got it yeah go [ __ ] do
something that you know walk around with
the confidence of three guys who just
got off the [ __ ] life sentence it's
the truth it's it's lately I just been
watching little things and going it's
routine I understand why this isn't
working I see all these and like I said
on the weekends I'm on the road that
computer is such a nightmare that
surface that I would leave oh all I had
access to was hotmail which I have on
the phone yeah God and I have Twitter on
the phone so people get pissed at me
like you know how come we don't pirate
you know you can't periscope in a hotel
room man yeah I'll go to jail for 20
years
I gotta pound the weed up everything
yeah it's a [ __ ] thing I have I got
[ __ ] paper pens that's that's [ __ ]
that now put in every if they want to
use it that's [ __ ] the control
substance those little baby back yeah so
you never know what the [ __ ] you're
dealing with there you aren't thinking
you got a ticket and they're like don't
by the way this is a controlled
substance this is a class four felony
you [ __ ] you got bail your quotes on
Wednesday vapor pen people feel like
they got it [ __ ] that if you
they're living the life they're like
dude it's a I mean I don't know how many
instances security steps in and goes is
that a vape pen they don't ask at all
they don't even know unless you [ __ ]
walk by them blow and smoke in their
face if you tip that [ __ ] and
put it under something yeah directs way
it looks like a [ __ ] pen and then
make them men who show no who has
there's a friend of mine who's got a
little piece that you don't even know
it's a vapor but that's it
it's all the sword leave tell them what
I had the other day in Ontario there's
an infinitive ah it's a one-hitter
that's stacked with weed and hash
already already already selling CZs you
know they saw that perennial over here
you buy ten of those things and put them
in your shave kit and hope that the
[ __ ] plugins don't bounce they don't
hear a bunch of Christmas lights in your
bag why you travel with shea butter wait
why you travel with Christmas lights
yeah but though you take one of those
out before you go on stage you only
rolling papers not only would do we get
high or did we get on we always get high
we got high dog we blast it away yo do
you think you do you think you just as
much take from like when you watch and
you getting influenced by comedy and
acting and do you feel like you get
influenced just as much by routine you
know I'm saying were you like just
hearing you talk about like the way your
routine has transformed over the years
and the way that you start to like you
know set up your day that probably
changed from how you do things now to
from two years ago right so you watched
observe you
you have enough conversations with
people with where you go oh that's the
way you do it
well maybe I'll do it that way or at
least take a piece of that I get
influenced by [ __ ] cuz we all are
anything yeah well the smallest thing I
might get Heine Tuesday like the doubt
of The Comedy Store I got a spot at
10:45 I'll go back that 8:45 yeah I'll
be excited about watching [ __ ] Holly
Wong you
but guess what Adam ray if I can win up
this time do some crazy [ __ ] they make
me laugh the [ __ ] so and you
learned something yeah I always when I
work with people I always [ __ ] with them
especially with a young kind of yeah I
go would you learn tonight and they
always look at me like what the [ __ ] he
asking me that for and I go listen
you're not gonna know the answer right
now but you want to check in with them
and be like where you've been thinking
about trying to learn something right
away because you should I call you
onstage you know effect this up yeah at
least I don't know five years in or
something from watching you know pros
like yourself where you're like you can
wear if you find yourself in a
conversation with people after I said
and you heard them dissecting pros and
cons or just like what I didn't do right
but also like oh man this moment was
cool yeah it was what was happening with
this joke oh I was trying this was doing
this just hearing that they were
immediately thinking about it made me go
you should be you should get offstage
and immediately kind of be like I don't
know reviewing things so what for you to
ask like what did you learn like you
should be thinking about that right
after right that's how you get better I
didn't know about it while I was doing
it another thing about five years in
yeah I used to ask myself and my well I
would get coked up in my cocaine stage
I've never done cocaine but I would love
less sure I don't yeah but right but I
guess what I'll do it if you wanted to
do it no yeah I should not even have
that it's so funny how you you my mom
told me to say that I first got into
comedy there was a lot of people like
Rick oh yeah my friends that did it for
some people at work before they went
onstage for me and just [ __ ] did and
I remember one man I got into an
argument with some [ __ ] jerk-off at
the store comic and he said to me cuz I
guarantee you wouldn't be funny if he
didn't do coke before I went onstage he
says and I said to myself is this gonna
[ __ ] we thought it no I didn't know
that if yeah I thought he knew you know
and then after a while it had just
become a respected yeah like listen Joey
I understand you're a junkie but this is
what you want to tell you do
yeah [ __ ] you though so listen yeah the
coke was there won't be up all [ __ ]
night but let me do this set and take
care of this so that was the pep talk I
would give myself so sure I would do a
15 that was set but I'd spend an extra
45 hours on cocaine even though I was
losing I was really women you know
saying but I was really winning because
at least I did my spot and I gave
yourself a ball I gave myself to respect
to respect the art of what we're doing
hey let me tell you something I'm not
ever gonna lie the entire I would go to
Miami and I get there on a Monday night
starts going on Monday by [ __ ]
Thursday
you're basically dog [ __ ] on stage
because again you said earlier there's
no emotion in your comedy you're Tom's
got a best uh it's uh what do you call
those [ __ ] mannequins what but he's
not mad Marta Gonzalo what do you call
those people that just stand there
Millennials know when you go to the
department store mannequins mannequins
you're just the mannequin on stage by
the way there was like an episode from
$25,000 pyramid things that stand there
lifeless uh my first time [ __ ] uh
was totally brother dog Tony bang will
something to break up the show in the
middle here I like that we don't [ __ ]
around here at him right oh I respect
this [ __ ]
you
but then I went on the road with like
Paul Mooney a couple times
rogon dice and you learn from everybody
you go out with yeah and you put you
know well learns from returns well and
from Todd Jordan they all had the same
quality of giving a young comic a chance
and give them advice and you know even
though we're not the funniest people in
the world they see something that
they've given us to work to open up for
them
yep gives us a little boost of
confidence yep Rogen really smooth it
all out
I mean him and Todd Jordan what a tool
guys that were like John Gotti they
really add a class to the business in my
field you know I'm saying when you
travel with Joe its class ain't a
[ __ ] Z there's no misunderstanding
I'm saying like it was just even in the
very beginning you were like Jesus
Christ this is like a dream come true
that's mine everybody else I work for
you after this you got not Rogan takes
care you just got an email
BAM yeah gonna peel this Jesus Christ
and it spoils you but it also shows you
the boundaries of what you could be
doing you know I mean I'm being in all
the clubs of them before he went into
theaters it was just eating me Ari
or me Ari in him or sometimes it was me
and Duncan on our each L didn't give a
[ __ ]
well he was on Fear Factor he was
bringing nine [ __ ] with him
why'd he Bravo to train with tape oh
yeah no he's row 7 [ __ ] deep that
those people are staying until he goes
on stage we like let's pack it in right
give us each 12 minutes ah he would pay
us each the same all great money he paid
us to fly you know sometimes he'd
upgrade to the first-class if there was
room hey you know when you went thee you
don't go to [ __ ] White Castle joke
you know the first thing you see him do
is typing up some [ __ ] steakhouse and
in those days we were just going to the
Brazilian steakhouse yeah so we would
roll in there eight deep get an eight
man payable and eat that [ __ ]
restaurant I was four [ __ ] hundred
pound people I'd see these white people
what's the name of the place it's all
gonna debt at that place is what people
have had heart attacks you are full of
try after every meet there right yeah
but let's say it depends on what you eat
and how big your stomach is and how much
hunger you have listen man when I was
Lee's age and I went out at night I
don't have to lie to you guys I could
kill a 24-ounce piece of meat with a
baked potato salad clams oreganata up
front maybe a bowl of [ __ ] the pasta
fazool with a [ __ ] with three or four
Coca Cola's you know I can't do that now
no I go to [ __ ] morons with my wife I
get to 12 months I cut it in half I need
six ounces there I take the other six
for breakfast and I even cut that out of
my diet that was it that's too much
[ __ ] meat especially when you put
that stake in in the morning and gosh
yeah buy a boner or was crying
you eat the [ __ ] thing that you get
depressed [ __ ] that [ __ ] know how to
kill these parabolas anymore but every
time you eat certain animals like my
bacon from marine Thiet makes me very
happy I know that bacon was killed I
know the pig they killed them all right
they rubbed his back Vito Genovese style
they stuck a pencil and that was it I'm
saying you want to know that if I know
you're kicking at me [ __ ] oh you know it
tastes different no it does do you feel
the pain you do you could taste the pain
in the animal like chicken I don't trust
chicken no more but sometimes why not
because when and what was your ultimate
trust in chicken era about six years ago
yeah I had some chicken and that's when
I found that when they were beating
chickens up no lay the chicken I could
tell if it's been beat up to smacked
around oh yeah I got it
victim look we all know the ball tastes
make them with domestic violence we all
know that chicken you could taste energy
like those Boston Market oh my god those
chickens are you now have a good life no
no they drop in they drop them or from
from the church you ever say it's those
type of chickens they're all depressed
she's a big be another I'm not gonna go
home and ruin someone's day on Yelp but
on the podcast I'm talking the truth a
Boston Market stopped beating new
chickens god I used to go to Boston
Market open those chickens were healthy
they had life they were happy when you
ate the chicken oh they sent you letters
the chest you could tell by the breast
if they're happy they get when you get
the bread look up it's got a spring
chest it's got a lot of [ __ ] big up
in there there's a lot of meat that
[ __ ] laid the chicken you take
you go find right now and chicken from
Boston Market how big it was and how
moving a chicken from Boston Market is
now now they get these chickens don't
even let them grow they're like homonym
would testify like I'm back in the day I
don't know nothing about that yeah yeah
I know they were getting beat up though
how do you know because that was a kid
you went on my mother went to a place
and got the chickens directly and they'd
skin they take the feathers they chop
her head off
they cut them into body parts and they
sold him wait that huh I would look at
the chicken before you [ __ ] brought
it home you had to pick the chicken look
at Minnie I know I'm gonna take you home
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] my mom didn't believe in
frozen chicken that's why when I go to
somebody's house I see somebody with a
bag of frozen chicken cutlets my heart
stops that's the worst thing you could
eat I know people wait that for years
why is that the worst because that poor
chicken has been through debt you don't
think it's those chickens they just
froze him alive [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah they
put them in the freezer like like a
narcos and make them walk into a freezer
with a blindfold on
oh my reasons of death they take them
out they're dead do they chop them up
when they melt no you do with lobsters
isn't that nice
what's happening tonight
you ever taste those sad laughs the same
thing with sad lobster yeah sometimes I
think they're opening for hooting the
Blowfish
laughs it tastes kind of weird when it's
juicy oh and it's got that sweetness to
it and the mane is very soft and when
you dip it in the butter some of the
meat and breaks that's a happy lobster
he had a happy life
well the ops just love butter right I
don't know what the [ __ ] they're gonna
get butter on the [ __ ] water Adam
right
wait think they got a supermarket on the
water and they swim in there and go we
gotta pound the bottom of this [ __ ] let
me get some shoutouts oh my god [ __ ]
yeah leave how you feeling over there we
had some stars we had a good time you're
off till next week no what are you gonna
do for way but any thoughts I know not
sure yeah maybe we'll know Airbnb maybe
are you gonna ambien be able to have you
seen your screens in a while port Renea
Lucas Bradley Meghan seven one five I
love you rob Marley Debbie if I got his
best
Jeremy Slade got my main man Don
Wrangler and the [ __ ] King of Swing
Steve grizzly are you [ __ ] kidding me
or what twenty your life no-parole you
know I'm saying you go on the road still
a lot yeah I've been on the road as we
just talked about I did Janie's rosemont
pass for the first time so I mean I've
been on the road for the last three four
months and that's what my special
Heather's solid I just I just watch it
again
two weeks ago and and then I was just -
I want to see the room and I'm gonna
read watch your [ __ ] and it was just
like he got me really pumped to be there
that has a great it's an unbelievable
room unbelievable city and I don't know
I I dig the robber now I've always been
headlining for man since 2013 so about
four years so I still really enjoy it
and a lot of new cities getting to go to
and now I'm getting to go back to places
like a second and third time and it's
fun no you don't a lot of television the
last couple years
ah boy I'm gonna big Kirby enthusiasms
coming back in October I'm in that
okay you're the old no the new one it's
coming back there's a new season yeah
did you get a few episodes uh yeah and a
couple Netflix movies coming out and
then you know Brad Williams and I who is
getting married this weekend and my
podcast partner about last night and I
had to which I don't know one with Josh
wolf for sports comedy one and we
stopped doing that so now it's just mine
and Brad Williams it's called it out
last night what you would feel doing a
celebrity no that's a different dude
Theo does one with again laughing : a
puke all this yeah I mean Brad Nutter
getting some gangsters yeah we got Reese
Witherspoon coming up Sandra Bullock
[ __ ] man Goo Goo Dolls TJ Miller Zac
Efron some cool people coming up yeah I
mean well look I mean it's like again
like we've talked about you you you get
to certain place and you just try to
like hope that you can you know be
genuine with your intentions on you know
when you meet somebody and then you like
my buddy Meyers in this movie with Reese
Witherspoon coming up and he's brought
my podcast a bunch and he I hit him up
and was like hey we should get you and
Reese on and he was like [ __ ] yeah and
then I went through his publicist and
like now it's gonna hatch so it's just
you know trying to think outside the box
and do that [ __ ] but you know there's
also times where I reached outside my
boundaries I feel I can end up somebody
to do it and then they'll say what are
you [ __ ] crazy like John Stamos
because he's afraid of little people and
Brad and Brad him badan him got into a
thing and we've been people man at one
point we were tweeting them non-stop
like come on the podcast and face your
fears and what does he think is gonna
happen
opening quit just make you nervous bro
some people make you know telling the
Brad I don't know and that may just made
him nervous when I was growing up had
you met a little person so you met Brad
for sure right how many how many though
how many what little people had you met
until Brad 15 that's how [ __ ] dude
that's a big number and I met him in the
seventies when little people were
gangstas is [ __ ] way wide to me that was
this and tell me I don't even know if
Brad knows the LP history
there was this bother my mother used to
go to seventies minutes what are they
there was some West New York New Jersey
and every time I get packed
about 4:30 right before we get into
really leave to go eat dinner this
midgel coming mmm let me give you a card
free um no and on the car with sign
language but connected to the card was a
pen with the American flag on okay so
you look at the car he'd go throughout
the whole ball right and at the end he
walked back in the air there actually
sir mmm-hmm and even you gave him a
dollar he took back the [ __ ] thing
from you right mm-hmm
and he took it back from you when I was
a kid I was so [ __ ] creeped out the
first time this guy walk ball I didn't
know what the thing yeah universe I
never really seen come on
and then I saw my mother did something
with numbers so we had to go to this
boss or whenever I was with my mom on
this particular day we would have to go
in on everything at one time the place
was [ __ ] backed by the way mmm it's a
great nickname for anybody dollar piece
to get it to like like in a unit lesson
if you didn't give him a dollar
I feeling him and it was like the
seventies a dollar was a lot of money
but if you but was it was dollar then
yes he's looking for a dollar okay so he
would sit there take a man stop darling
cuz he would go what you just come on
that's like me coming up to you with a
bucket like the Honda commercial yeah an
act of good faith
you know when they show up and give away
ice cream and then not once that they
had a chick show up it's like you'd
think that's the act of kindness right
there
that's what everything's a Honda you
know saying when I see them show up with
three hot chicks
to your corporation like a place that
works for midgets or something like that
they got a bunch of people disabled and
they come in and start sucking that
little [ __ ] big Honda never wear the
blue shirts yeah they have the blue
shirts on and this little [ __ ] comes
clattering anyway oh my god hilarious
but they don't do that huh I ain't got
the balls they want to go give up
milkshakes there's there's a lot of
commercials and sponsors that could take
a lot more risks Charles didn't did it
when they had titties and [ __ ]
barbecue so you got to push the envelope
so I went there about four months later
he walks it and by this time I was a
scandal it was about he would threaten
someone every every day that was his job
yeah he's committed to a life a pin you
know in those days Guttenberg New Jersey
in 19 he's never called Guttenberg from
1980 after 1990 something and more bars
per capita than anywhere else in the
country
no [ __ ] if you walk through Guttenberg
you hit 20 bars and it's only two or
three blocks long that what the original
Vegas no [ __ ] New Jersey you [ __ ]
Vegas and it's in a hot spot a lot of
times you look at pictures of New York
City that's gotten burned because
Guttenberg is like from 79th Street to
71st okay 69th Street to 71st Street man
so it goes from Boulevard East to I
think maybe
no it goes into life like the third
Avenue before Kelly Boulevard they just
made up a town one day somebody came in
with a big
sorry great proposed look in those days
before the subway big money in those
neighborhoods in those days was what
bars yeah you know people were drinking
people the Vietnam War was anything you
know there was a lot of sports going on
what do you think prompts the most
rockin boxing was on television for free
there was no pay-per-view it was on wor
if some of these bars almost benefit
more so by not charging for the fight
don't you agree well if they try if they
don't charge it cost him $10,000 well
they go back a pass right I guess so
uber walks in all right he goes all the
way and he's welcome back and finally
and this guy goes in this pocket and
he's got a wild like this he's got a
whole hour bill he posed a hundred on he
knows you got change of a hundred I
think I goes I got in my pocket
give me that [ __ ] thing back and they
smacked him a few times they throw I
never saw him again that's it he was a
fake
he was a Fugazi deaf dude oh that was
his living you know how much money you
can make holder if you go into [ __ ]
30 bars at $2 a piece that's 60 bucks
but he was really a little person yeah
sometimes he'd take the Fiat so he could
tell you anything I shot his leg they
can tie anybody yeah you know it was
crazy people I think it he's probably
still around his way to living it look
him up he's on Facebook never paying
taxes I don't know how to spell that you
know I get creative there was so many
things like that that people did face
[ __ ] like that would that it's kind of I
would always look at this ballsy yeah I
would look at me oh Jesus Christ your
[ __ ] is no end I saw I saw a video the
other week of this guy doing just that
he's pretend to be like special I'm
pretty sure I could try to find the
video if you want and so until the news
called them on it
are you still have to what sure do what
will be special I can't remember and be
special I can't exact I don't want to
misquote the video it's only trying to
find it no it's small people I was
saying but my podcast first when I was
rather bragging may had first they would
they would they were to scam me but
after her that's right then I knew a
couple in Jersey when I moved to Jersey
with
no city do you remember what you felt or
what you you know to me
look I didn't I mean this I think I
think people over you know when I hear
people like Stamos or anybody that has
like a phobia or says anything off-color
to joke it which is basically kind of
deflecting their own insecurities about
being around when I'm like they're
people there it's a person
it's a little bit smaller and you know
so make that adjustment and like I can
you know I don't know how people that I
Stamos what are you doing what you're
afraid of you're afraid of a person like
what are you doing this is a smaller
person exact dude you can't be [ __ ]
this size of a kid yeah you know have
the baseball skills I'm a [ __ ] relief
pitcher how many how many people will
fire you reshape their hand because they
have germophobia
yeah you know that just went to the
store a couple weeks ago and he was on
the stage and he wouldn't shake the guy
that brought him up he wouldn't shake my
hand and I get it I [ __ ] get it
sometimes I think it's a fake phobia
it's a phobia to be cool but I can't see
how much for being as little people you
know maybe it's insane to me and it is
it's obvious it's been security yeah
it's when you look at somebody and go
you know what I feel kind of guilty I'm
not gonna deal with it because I had
that growing up sometimes about certain
things that I'd see and I don't know
what he had a [ __ ] dope yeah we're
all products of our environment are you
finding this this special needs video
I'm trying what you Google by the way oh
[ __ ] uh-huh yeah this is it Gary
Thompson Kentucky beggar who fakes
having a disability earns a hundred
thousand a year holy [ __ ] he's the
greatest actor of all time they they
work it and they work the system and you
how often have you heard about there's a
certain street corner when I pull off a
freeway accident when I'm home in
Seattle and there's always somebody
always someone perched up there right
there was just always someone with a
sign at this freeway exit it's like just
a classic
spot like you're literally like it's
almost like you're all gonna be always
gonna be that light for at least three
to five minutes so there's always a
decent amount of time if you could go
through the emotions of recognizing the
sign seeing the person you have enough
time to size them up and decide if you
want to if you think money's gonna help
do you have the money like what's going
on with you right now
alright I've watched the report with
especially the guy appeared as a guy
appears somewhere but I've heard of
these guys like bacon they find the good
spots they check them out and one day
the cameras follow them
eyewitness form and they'd show him
[ __ ] like staying out there from 6
a.m. to 10 a.m. rush hour for hours
they'd pick up the bucket they'd walk
two blocks they'd make a left walk
another block and then get into their
brand-new yeah SUV and drive wall and
drive over you have no idea listen it
was lasting there's a gas the homeless
guy tenders to six to ten thirty who
were black draft for a left and dirty he
for him there and get what the [ __ ]
and one day then one day they pours out
are to see John one day the
investigative report pulled up as he was
getting again out of the parking spot
and he rolled his window down and then
what we were watching you have footage
of you how can you do such a thing and
the guy's like hey we got a whole week
but he had no [ __ ] shame and the
other sign that he had three missing
kids and all [ __ ] deal there was a
guy on my old street and I think they
made a move but he has a he would always
wear denim everything had a sign that
his house was gonna be foreclosed on you
did it right by the mall he was there
every day I bumped into a guy its commit
you know I bumped into it about six
seven I moved up here in 2009
yeah thousand ten I've moved on this
block at the end and we were living in
one man walking some mangos Joey okay
what's happening how you doing man you
know I was the camera guy I'm this movie
we shot you shot three days on you went
with I didn't remember my god but I
couldn't tell him that yeah so good to
see you evil working my game and thus it
was something my wife was either
pregnant or something his wife he's wife
sees well my wife's a realtor we started
talking about me that's funny we were
looking for a house for a place to move
to and I connected her with my wife with
him my wife comes back I shouldn't say
those ladies I don't want my creepy
[ __ ] why should I think Oh what type
of questions well she wants this this
this this this what's up man no [ __ ]
way - I give certain [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] if it as a relationship you don't
like there's no reason why you should
have that information and sure enough
you got omit some stuff right these
people were living in people's guest
houses yanks like there are all those
people if they were faking the guy
always look like a [ __ ] bum and then
one day when my dad came into our
podcast
yeah like three years later yeah I tell
him my doubt stay over here is a happy
and be at my buddy owns he's a down the
corner over here we could pick you up
now on my own Airbnb you pick some
[ __ ] hub in North Hollywood I mean
where you could see it take Cho people
before you could smell the Gunpowder in
here and when I pick them up the one day
they keep telling me to pick him up the
guy who was renting that house was that
dude and his wife no that's how they
were making a living they were right
in the house and Airbnb in the house
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy listen you're
all done I don't know what about three
years ago I signed with CAA
I knew this chick and she started
commercial AIDS I said I called one in a
spoken-- and I been with listen I've
been with a lot of populations how many
she's so many commercial agents at that
time that was maybe my fourth in 15
years make a 17 years yeah I'm already
did 20 years yet I was your main
commercial during that time was that the
one that you were like [ __ ] II I got
that my first commercial ever time the
first one with the dog the Taco Bell oh
I just moved here cheap money oh yeah I
don't know what it's like that's what
the old days for commercials did [ __ ]
my first got here welcome to outlets are
you this one sailor forum had nothing to
do a man
I lived on Hollywood Boulevard before
you hit my brave those buildings that
all look the same
yeah on the left-hand side don't let you
move in they were bad credit no credit
east of La Brea right yeah like if I
don't know that [ __ ] Boy Scout
you're one Hollywood Boulevard I don't
get about the hip [ __ ] labret I don't
got a compass yeah I don't know about
east-west and then we lived in there
what the [ __ ] was I even talking about
about living all about the commercial
80s yeah I was with Sutton Barton Renard
for a [ __ ] seven years man and then I
went with nobody for a while
and I tried these guys in Beverly Hills
but they were a pain the ass and I
haven't even fired him that was he got a
Taco Bell commercial yeah okay so I
moved down here and I got a Taco Bell
commercial and that's when you make cash
but when I lived in those apartments yes
there was a kid that was a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
his girlfriend was a 12 she was 22 he
had that [ __ ] stripper
over at
Jumbo's fun no let's see a like I'm
naked making a nickel a night off a
[ __ ] Sean Penn and the fat [ __ ] who
killed himself with the cocaine and oh
yeah
that place over there is a [ __ ] magnet
and where he but the place on what see
anything you're gonna see anything you
go towards the airport there's a place
on the right-hand side that's been this
is Jesus left Chicago here's the weird
thing
there's no real [ __ ] booth you gotta
watch him naked from 3 feet away
Hollywood has a law I personally went in
there to pick up my girl from one night
yeah and she goes you gotta go in there
and see this and it was the [ __ ] fat
do it before we died what's the name
Farley sweating profusely with his hair
combed back taking 50s or 20s and just
drawing him at the girl laughing by
himself that's how I knew he was out of
his [ __ ] mom well mrs. Bob maybe three
weeks before he done it shut the [ __ ] up
that strip club does every do those
girls and their make money but back to
the original story this loser
went to do a national commercial yeah
and it was Doritos trios was killing the
game for a little bit Jay Leno
dude the de-hype Doritos forget across a
little this guy was a guy like you that
neither the job I don't know everybody's
man shoots a commercial he goes how
Cleveland and he plays the guitar and he
picks up a bag of Doritos well they shot
the commercial yeah but then for an hour
or two or three hours they shot him with
different Dorito by or some all over the
world in different languages it's when
[ __ ] are no Jersey guitar just put a
bag of Doritos before it blew up they
just have him pick up a bag he would
play the guitar go hello Cleveland ma'am
and he pick up a back at the retos eat
it he fall in the arena and all the kids
would go ah there he does like ready he
read it like 10 different
he didn't even [ __ ] know what he had
done no he came home thinking you know
I'm getting scale I booked the
commercial I'm so excited about it
[ __ ] six weeks later he comes in he's
like you gotta see this [ __ ] check I
got it and the first like it was 1998
97 and this check had to be like his
first check after resigning winks was
like no it was like 22,000 because they
had to pay him for each market of the
world yeah it didn't like four days
after there you got like 40 G's because
in those days they didn't pay you like I
booked my international I walked into a
commercial and then this guy had already
put me into commercials in fact I talked
about what he said a construction worker
with a hammer come on I got this like a
mother you had construction work I
walked in there it's international
national [ __ ] prime the wood whatever
they call the prime time time you know
they have a name for it now it's full
nationalism big national or something
else it had 20 different categories I'm
thinking big money big money that dude
that was my neighbor moved out got moved
into a boot two-bedroom house in
Hollywood Boulevard somewhere and bought
a BMW he said he got checks for a long
time there's a scene in Titanic
yeah where a kid opens up the gate and
she gets in it he was an extra bro and
they picked them on location to do that
you know what his first verse is you'll
check what you don't want to know 50 G's
yeah those movies [ __ ] money those
first checks what do you do with that
money what do you think you do you snort
coke you get hookers
you pay your rent pay the insurance on
your car it's your first big driver Dave
& Buster's I don't know I don't know my
I mean my first big job did I got a 20k
one from the heat and I
put a bunch towards my car and some
loans and I took a couple grand of it
and was like I'm gonna go on a trip and
that's what I did right my first big
movie check was 36 miles I thought I was
jolly Gambino Wow I'm gonna go to the
check cashing place and Whitsett like
was going on this [ __ ] oh we got
enough money that can come with his cash
uncle Joey's here is shut up [ __ ]
lights and they take that [ __ ] five
percentage you know yeah it was crazy
like I owe it when I got here people are
talking about all this big money and
every movie I booked was [ __ ] scale
everybody would go oh wait you get a
[ __ ] pilot dog 30,000 every pilot I
shot five pilots and five pilot season
not one of them paid 10,000 [ __ ]
dollars
really one pilot paid me good because it
was CBS at 95 seven that we didn't even
[ __ ] I shot like two days on it maybe
maybe and they paid me a shitload of
dough for those times you know I'm
saying like that was like whoo I've been
starving for [ __ ] at that point I was
starving five years plus I was getting
chased by creditors I just gotten
divorced oh I was I'm [ __ ] mess I'll
go to comedy clubs there would be a
creditor on the phone they won't talk
about that man what's going on Discover
card you never sent this a payment what
and you imagine that haven't break I
went to the comic store getting ready to
go on stage they call yamas there's a
phone call for you and you pick it up
and say hi hi Adam American Express we
have a great set by the way and you're
like how they we don't get your payment
so we're not gonna ever get it my land I
am tomorrow we're gonna cut your [ __ ]
off and they can't cuz you're an addict
and there's a scam you got you go to a
restaurant you got a whole dollars worth
of food but the way that pockets fifty
in cells you have grammar coke like a
Mezzaluna that you're the place were
[ __ ] that well what's her name was
before she got slashed up and half
hojae's wife Mezzaluna was a place that
every tab was $3,000 lights but two
people go to dinner
that's a [ __ ] up [ __ ] restaurant in
Brentwood yeah before all that [ __ ] that
was a cocaine restaurant looking up that
got indicted three years after [ __ ]
Nicole got killed who was the weirdest
[ __ ] thing you dealing with does not
miss it
no no we think they would you think they
were dropping off sunglasses to Nicole's
somebody just told me that they're they
they were a was a Wayne Federman I think
you're waiting Federman yeah yeah I
think Wayne was telling me I feel like
it was him that was he was a bartender
or or at a restaurant in Brentwood that
Nicole come into and OJ and she would
leave and then he would just beeline to
these women at the bar and like get
their numbers oh yeah
like right after it was a disgusting
filthy relationship somebody had to die
and when i season the sopranos eyes
opened up that somebody's gotta go yeah
like those two were just doing nasty
[ __ ] it never all came out like nobody
knows the truth Oh somebody ended up
[ __ ] dead
that was some crazy [ __ ] think about
that for somebody that you dated I would
know him and I mean that woman that's a
crazy level you gotta get demons it
would you have to be this fat bald and
neck in Decapitator I'm right through a
pillow at an extra phone once and I felt
bad about that and it was like a soft
like it did I messed her up that people
hold on
that's the feds come when a black shirt
finally he admitted about the pillow
incident you know it's kind of crazy
that I can't imagine it try to like
actually hurt somebody that's crazy and
when we drive somebody [ __ ] kill
their wife their ex-wife especially the
mother or their [ __ ] child what they
were doing some dirty [ __ ]
you know it never came out to embarrass
the families and the kids you know
listen at the end they threw him in jail
they're gonna let him out what he ever
come to shows Willie why would he ever
come to shows I think he'd be stupid if
he left this house at this point he's a
little [ __ ] mad yeah he's more of
Florida now to do what to retire yeah
retired from the NFL Club you think so I
know so that's how he makes a living
that's how he makes a living from his
[ __ ] pension
missing meals that's why the Goldmans
can't type the goldmans can't touch his
budget by law so he laughs all the way
to the bed Wow he probably gets 20 grand
look up OJ's monthly pension you'll find
it your [ __ ] head oh man dude woody I
gone dude if I did hopefully you're
giving most that to kids and then maybe
you're going to Dave & Buster's like two
days out of the week get some tickets
get some [ __ ] prizes get a bouncy
ball he probably owes some money for
this defense he'll go there he'll go
there by the way that sends in that
voice will never be setting down no I
need to go there dude you know what
though the NFL seems like the [ __ ]
ticket right so crazy 25 grand a month
again oh my god that's three hundred
thousand a year that he lives off he'll
go to Florida Plus now he has to get
Social Security and SSI and all that
other [ __ ] that comes with it he'll get
himself a nice little small place and
fly if he's smart the first time they
take a picture him with a white woman
he's back in the [ __ ] music yeah you
can't go outside man so you know that's
the property really it was he's 64
whatever how much longer does he have on
this body he's 70 he's 70 guys this
happened 24 years ago 25 23 I don't
[ __ ] know the math you know so who
knows how they gonna treat him now let
him go into a community and die dog in a
way paid for his sins he doesn't get to
raise his kids he didn't go to a lot of
graduations he didn't he was in [ __ ]
jail God knows what you for how long
this last time he was in there for a
while the first time he was in there
family was like nine years oh yes right
no listen listen he killed her God knows
why he killed them you know who the [ __ ]
knows who the [ __ ] knows that there was
an accomplice it was one of those
relationships bro that was toxic we date
for a while we break up I [ __ ] somebody
that's your friend you [ __ ] somebody it
was my friend then we try to make it
work with something
- let's let's let's but let's let's
quickly recognize the the willingness to
cut ties by a lot of people out there
right that goes oh [ __ ] like that
cheated on you're the cheater or
whatever it is and you never ate when
you cheat on before she goes out and
sucks a dick or vice-versa
yeah you know how many times can I catch
you cheating on me before I go out and
[ __ ] somebody or get rid of you and to
stay in it like what do you what do you
bring in to the table or the table he
was bring it to the table he we gave the
parents on our parents of franchise and
whatever and I hate to say it this way I
really do ladies and gentlemen but this
is how you have to look at it whenever
they went to Mezzaluna or any other best
restaurant the [ __ ] played for dinner
you know so that's the truth that's
saying that's the right way
yeah he's paying he's he's [ __ ] my
wife you know they knew he was beating
her if you knew that a man was beating
your daughter but now I'm gonna
predicament I own the [ __ ] hearse
Rascar thing that you gave me oh how am
I gonna get rid of my daughter well my
other pain my duck yeah there's a lot of
little things that were never really
people didn't look at the people only
looked at the [ __ ] big picture they
never really looked at all the little
things that were being affected you
insane but at the end
komm is always dead a knock on your door
they always said coma he's always gonna
send you a receipt you imagine Bill
Cosby a bro
the last dirty Isabel Cosby's life what
he did to people and one day when you
retired all you should be doing is being
at home counting 20s I'm watching TV and
getting your foot rub by Chinese people
hopefully some [ __ ] black comedian
says that you were a rapist and lights
on fire 60 women come out of the grave
and now no on trial again he's on trial
again when you 70 what causes that [ __ ]
to happen what causes a mafia captain
to be a [ __ ] mobster all his life
kill people maybe do four years here but
his he left money his kids are well
educated he goes into his 50 he become a
captain maybe he becomes an underboss
now he's making 200 grand a month
everybody's eating [ __ ] lobster the
kids are living in a mansion to where
your kids are in private school and one
day at 6:00 a.m. mr. Cosby it's the
federal [ __ ] government and they come
in they take everything you got they put
you in jail for the rest of your life
and your kids have to live like [ __ ]
mooks Oh like like what's that [ __ ]
dude they did an HBO about the [ __ ]
swindler oh um Madoff imagine one is
killed themself man at that point of
your life oh dude you lived your whole
life like a savage and all son you're
gonna die in the can as an old man you
don't it's like to be an old man in
prison do you have any [ __ ] idea
huh nyquil dreams about it it's not a
[ __ ] pretty sight man it's not a
pretty sight
so those guys that live all their lives
like captains and all son died in a
[ __ ] prison
karma always says your [ __ ] receipt
yeah
karma always sounds like you're speaking
t-shirts Joey I speak and [ __ ] the
church what's happened now when's the
next club you're gonna be at West Palm
Beach improv September 7th through the
9th if this comes out before then well
yeah yeah September 7th through the
nothing here you know I I was having a
flashback to the you know summers you
you know there's certain things you do
in there I remember when I first went
podcast first hit and they were still
like a handful out there but then like
there was I would be on the road and
there were some kid be like hey we might
do minor to McDonalds and I was like you
know what I'm gonna do a podcast and
then he was like I'll put this up in
like three weeks cuz I got to get my
audio [ __ ] together and I was like
whatever was that what was I doing also
I know you you get a lot of heavy
hitters coming through so I don't know
when that's gonna drop but tomorrow we
don't covet our [ __ ] podcast also all
those OJ shit's super topical so we
gotta get it out no we were just talking
about a situation where we were it's not
a super topical it's that we're talking
about color and how it affects different
totally and also say this about that Eau
de [ __ ] like how many instances in the
entire history of our country have
happened to where I mean yo I heard some
Eau de [ __ ] like a week ago and I was
[ __ ] riveted you know I'm saying like
there's certain things that you're just
like he lived like a king oh dude I was
in a conversation was with some people
and some like yourself that were like
someone attached to like what was
happening and I couldn't [ __ ] believe
what I was listening to you know I was I
was so you know again just overwhelmed
with the amount of information I was I
was getting towards me West Palm Beach
improv September 7th through the 9th
Tempe improv Tropicana Laugh Factory
Vegas all Adam ray comedy calm look at
you got any movies coming out yeah a
couple of Netflix and Suzy Korean thew Z
as I'm about last night podcast of Brad
Williams a few of the things in the
works and I'm able to get a friend that
is including Brad I defend nobody I'm
old school I grew up on [ __ ] I love it
too like no it's a in my jokes up in my
jokes when I have a toast or I saw like
growing a [ __ ] by the way is the name
your sitcom budgets hopeful you know
used to torture midgets in his egg but
nice clay oh and I would [ __ ] die
when he talked about mazes what
laws and the big heads legit Casey would
say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
can I say this by Brad - leg on are
Brad's a super great super wicked and
also like it's just like it's really
like on top of him being a great
comedian like he makes you feel
comfortable around him he he goes out of
his way to recognize in certain
situations where people were like oh
[ __ ] like I haven't been around a little
person before yes come on and close eyes
he'll take the edge off people I've seen
him do he puts it on himself immediate
yeah yeah it's like a it's a very
underrated element of his personality
and his uh just who is the person where
he goes I don't want anybody feeling
comfortable around me and I want to be
able to I want to be comfortable around
them and turned but that being said when
I look it's a bummer that he's about to
get married and now he's not gonna be
making cookies anymore but you know it's
all good what's going on we say you get
those stars got to you lately cuz yeah
anyway you know depending on where you
get your mortgage you can save twenty
G's or more but any percent of people
only get one mortgage offer and if you
just go to your bank chances are you're
getting ripped off you're gonna get
screwed Lending Tree doesn't want this
to happen here's the thing the average
Lending Tree customer can save twenty
thousand over his life of their loan
that's average half of that customers
could save even more whether you're
looking for new mortgage refinance or
home equity loan Lending Tree is the
only place where you could get up to
five real offers from America's top
lenses and you can compare them
side-by-side for free and guess what it
only takes three minutes out of your
time listen three minutes ain't gonna
kill nobody
well my bank gave me the offer I have a
general one thing I looked at and I
didn't like it I said to back if I were
down with Lending Tree but I'm not ready
about when I do I'm going to London 3
it's like shopping for flights online
only you're shopping for the best
mortgage offers for you rates always go
up and down but regardless of what's
happening with the rates you can always
get the right offer for you with Lending
Tree calm I know you're sure you're
ready for the best deal find out on what
you can
save tonight Lending Tree calm / Church
today right now you're looking to buy a
house right here's your chance this is
how to get the party started
Lending Tree calm the / shirts again
Lending Tree calm / Church you'll get
five different offers Lending Tree calms
last Church LLC nmls number one one
three six terms and conditions apply
listen to me people I'm gonna talk to
you [ __ ] from Lourdes it's
August what twenty nine thirty half you
[ __ ] a scratch and thinking to
yourself I got the the right system this
year the bet I'm gonna go out and beat
the [ __ ] bookmaker way you go you
ready for this uncle Joey's ready is set
you up my bookie dot 8g ever since I
started this podcast every once in a
while people tweet us or ask us for
advice Lee and I always talk about the
Patriots he knows our money when I come
to the Patriots but people has Dallas
whatever let me tell you this when
you're bettin it's just as important as
who you betting on who you betting wit
it's just as important as who you
betting on you dig me so that's why I
always tell people to go to my bookie AG
my bookie has been in business for years
and their rep is rock-solid you dig they
do a hundred percent cash bonuses so off
that bat you're making money for doing
who gots nuttin and they got the fastest
payouts seriously just two business days
you're gonna meet some fat [ __ ] do it
at a diner on a Thursday at 4 o'clock
and he thinks he's Johnny Gambino and
he's nothing but a [ __ ] messenger
those days are over you know who's gonna
win right yeah lay down some cash and
win big today I'd recommend the service
to my listeners it's been good to me and
I know it's good to a lot of people
that's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie you know why because
when you win BAM they pay they have in
game live betting and most rewarding
player perks in the business and all new
mobile sites that makes wagering on the
go a breeze you understand me I do me a
favor is what I'm gonna do for you join
them I booked my booking
match deposit with up to a hundred
percent bonus of your first deposit up
to a thousand dollars use promo code
Church to activate the often few people
will don't watch Sesame Street si-hu rch
visit my bookie capital AG today and use
promo code Church you play you win you
get paid
you got a system put it to test this
miss week right now you got college on
Saturday get it together right now as we
talk get your account going go to my
bookie dot AG today and use promo code
Church cut the [ __ ] right take a
chance Columbus did Adam Wright thank
you for coming on no Lisa I yet nobody
loves you more than me [ __ ]
telling me I was sleeping my wife is
crying the Giants have lost that's
sudden that Monday night before that's
also a big deal that we will see you
this weekend have a great Labor Day
weekend be safe with your families stay
black I love you
[Music]
you